guys come see me at the west palm beach
improv december 4th and 5th come see me
at the shovel year theater in boston on
december 10th i'm really looking forward
to that it's almost sold out so get
tickets and then also almost sold out my
first time at the borgata in atlantic
city saturday december 11th all tickets
on sale at savile counter comedy.com
brian quinn will be at the show at the
borgata he just told me that and
there'll be other surprises hope to see
you there my dad will be there too all
right i'm on the road i'm chrissy
standups okay go to chrisdcomedy.com i
got a lot of stand up dates this
saturday i'm actually going to be in
newark new jersey at the victoria
victoria theater i don't think there's
any tickets left but if you want to come
and just stand outside and throw [ __ ] at
me december 2nd to the 4th phoenix
arizona december 17th 18th west palm
beach florida then i'm going on tour
with my baby sally volcano december 26th
grand prairie texas 27 san antonio 28th
sugarland
texas 29th chesterfield missouri 30th
columbus ohio 31st cincinnati baby then
january 14th 15th i'm in austin texas
and then the theater tour really takes
off january 21st i'm in orlando
co-headlining with [ __ ] andrew dice
clay okay chrissy died chrissy and the
diceman january 22nd tampa 20 at the
tampa theater 29th atlantic city at the
borgata then the biggest one ever
february 5th at the bbv beacon theater
new york city then february 11th
washington dc the warner theater and
it's called the end that they spell with
the knee so the warner thier tree then
february 12th atlanta georgia the
tabernacle march 4th royal oak michigan
march 5th cleveland ohio march 18
seattle washington march 19 portland
oregon march 25th las vegas
april 8th indianapolis april 9 denver
april 29th bethlehem pennsylvania and
april 30th philadelphia at the met i
know that's a lot of dates but i wanted
to just say this once on the pod so go
get those tickets if you live in those
cities and i really appreciate the
support christy comedy.com i am gay
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings
[Music]
what's up babe what's up baby you look
wow you all right what's up i'm fine
babe
no but your voice doesn't sound like
fine i don't know what you mean this is
my voice that's your voice yes do you
have
have do you have throat cancer
not that i'm aware of why do you ask
because they're saying one of the
leading causes of throat cancer in men
now is hpv in the throat have you been
going down on women my whole life
then you could have throat cancer
should we take a pause
i want to call my
primary care physician your pcp my pcp
pcp who's got pcp i'll take him down
i'll throw him in jail i would do pcp
dust it is called angel dust yeah or is
that lsd no pcp is angel dust i think
it's angel dust because i remember a
line from trading places
the eddie murphy vehicle never seen it
i've never seen training places are you
insane you've never seen trading places
i've never seen training places by the
way people who are listening to this on
audio only
on audio only will think i do have
throat cancer and listen
we're not saying i hope you don't but
who cares
listen people you
we're all gonna die something yeah
that's true by the way speaking forget
about your throat what have you been
what's your ab routine
i do crunches
with a 400 pound weight belt
400 pound weight belt yeah wow
amazing so you do that for two hours a
day two hours a day yeah oh my goodness
dude yeah i'm out
just perusing the streets you look good
now something's happened to your ears
too your ears look different
yeah yeah yeah
i've uh
i was on extreme
plastic surgery
wow
makeover
yeah wow i told him i want to look more
goth
goth yeah oh my god now it's happening
to me you see wow
and whatever you have is contagious yeah
well you really sound like an oval with
broken yeah let me just take a sip of my
dunkin donuts coffee america right
up in america runs on duncan
[Laughter]
so
time to make the donuts
time to make it remember that
it was a little right no not it
no
no it was an ad campaign with the guy
with the mustard wasn't he a little guy
no he was a regular sized man
pimp can you pull it up time to make the
donuts dunkin donuts time to make the
donuts
let's see this guy we might have put
pulled this up on the taste buds podcast
oh taste buds
the counter rose is a real joker
[Laughter]
time to make the doughnut oh 1984 tv
commercial that's when i was born oh wow
year i was born 1984. oh wow look at
this guy
dunkin donuts is the best though
not better than hello fresh doughnuts no
butcher box donuts are also amazing yeah
i love the donuts from keeps.com
as your hair falls out you make a donut
um
babe
babe man let me tell you something
i
went to the new york knicks game the
other night yeah i asked you to go but
you said you had a mission i had spots
oh you had spots
right i had just booked them and i was
like five of them and i couldn't cancel
i was so upset that i couldn't go with
you wait a minute now that sounds like
your voice you need to go to the doctor
you're right
wait are you all right i
something happens it goes it goes in and
out okay well we'll keep an eye on it
pimple pimple edit around it pimp keep
an eye on this point please because i
don't know if people are going to want
to hear for the whole episode or not i
got you
email the podcast heypodcast gmail.com
so we go to the knicks game yeah me and
pimp first of all
like lights out drunk again i got this
is now i am not you don't i don't think
you get lights out drunk with me yep i
was i was happy we got lit up i i open b
i oh yeah you know how it is you know
you go to the same same thing
open b oh
so what we started doing yeah is we
started drinking and this is now
becoming like a relatively noticeable
issue where three to four nights a week
i'm like
legitimately drunk are you doing
drinking during spots
yes i'm drinking at the comedy clubs and
if i go out but now there's also beers
in the fridge i got sam adams
oktoberfest shout out santana's
octoberfest and we've been drinking two
or three of them at night every night at
dinner i mean you know vince they go
down smooth she's just making tortellini
with string beans like you know like you
know bertolli throw it right in the pot
nothing fancy no with texas toast garlic
bread but we're having i'm having three
oktoberfest sounds delicious to me and
also that sounds like the perfect
accoutrement for the for the meal
coochman yeah it's a great question the
kid the kids the kids get a little apple
juice and we and the adults get
oktoberfest because i'm down sam's and i
put down stamps and i'm putting on
weight
um putting on you putting on i see you
got a little sam adams yeah yeah
a little set no i don't i don't i do go
for i don't
i went for a brisk walk today through
clove lakes park shuttle club lakes oh
my god is it your first time there one
of the first times yeah is it not one of
the best parks one of the best you know
it's way bigger than you probably think
it's on both sides of the air yeah why i
jogged i shot secret hidden spots in
there too there's like trails that you
don't know about really have you taken
me years to find out what i was gonna
say have you do you think you've been
through every step of that oh yeah
because i learned how to ride a bicycle
there when i was like four so you were
just you you were just
silver like not as big you know vinnie
uh what's his name from entourage how he
is queen's boulevard yeah i am clovely
you want cleveland
so so um you see the ducks
by the way shout out mustard seed cafe i
went in there the other day and they
said thanks for all the shout outs so i
shot them get out of here thanks for the
shout out but did charge me full price
no i'm kidding they didn't actually they
didn't they can't do that she gave it to
me all for free i i which i appreciate
it you gave me my food and bevs for free
um when i come in next time i i want to
pay full price i love the business i
love the much cheaper i haven't been
there i got to try it out we got to go
all right we got a nice little outdoor
seating area forest avenue yeah um
so we go to the next game yeah we go to
the knicks game i get absolutely wrecked
me and the me the pimp and i yeah get
absolutely go new york go new york
fat joe is right in front of us spike
lee
right we're having a good time
we got great fat joe line or is it a big
pun line it's fat joe what what's he
saying in the middle a little little
little do we know
diddly oh it doesn't say that it is fun
probably yeah ben stiller's there okay
so at first we say listen don't even
make eye contact ben stiller ben stiller
from the ben stiller show from the ben
stiller show wow yes don't even make eye
contact with him i said i'm gonna put my
head down keep my head down keep my man
shut mouth shut because i made a mistake
a couple of years ago saying hello to
cuba gooding junior and that did not
work out well uh
junior was like don't talk to me in this
sweet homes and i was oh my god yeah and
i was like okay i'm sorry really i was
like i'm sorry mr cube he was abrasive
he was drunk and then you know a couple
of weeks later came out in the paper
that he was getting he was getting drunk
and and lit up with a lot of people for
those weeks i think he got a little bit
of trouble for something i don't know
what cuba good and junior did allegedly
yeah he's just he's not on on the map
the way he used to be i think when he
played the radio the character yeah i
think after that things took a little
bit of a turn he got lost in the
character he got lost in the character
so ben stiller now pimp is saying that i
gave him an awkward handshake but pimp i
got to be honest with you i'm so drunk i
don't remember awkwardly are you getting
stiller what did i do to him we got
hammered and we went up for one more
round of drinks and he was going on the
elevator and you just went up to him as
if you knew him 100 and i kind of forced
him into like a hug pound situation
that's right i did do that i forced ben
stiller into like a hug and a smile
and that was like was he was he he just
went along with it yeah he was pretty
nice guy you know like he he's super i
met him a couple times he's always been
super nice i met him in 1995. really you
got picks
yeah i have it i met him in 1990 i met
him in 1995 on the set of nypd
blue
he was in nypd
it filmed at a soundstage in la i think
it was like where they filmed like uh
it was i think it was paramount nypd
blue
filmed in l.a yeah just like
philadelphia cream cheese made in new
york the whole world's a sham the whole
world's a sham yeah and uh we were on
set for a couple of days
and why were you on set
i was v it was the first time i was on
our airplane it was january 1995 i went
to visit a friend in la with two other
friends i was never on an airplane
before we went for two two weeks to la
wow and we were fascinated with the
movie biz and so we hit up all the you
know the studios tours went out my
friend's dad had an in at the movie
studios so we went there and we were
supposed to be escorted and they let us
in and then no one escorted us so we
free roam the movie studios for days can
you flip that the other way the dunkin
donuts thing yeah just the other yeah
you want to see the qr code no no i want
to see the straw pointing away from you
got it like god bless you and your
family there it is scan the qr code for
rewards with the dunkin donuts app wow
qr codes are big now
what is what is more popular than the qr
code qr code tattoo right to my freaking
cheek like our hip hop star when you
click on it you can buy tickets to my
shows why don't you do that that's being
done that's being done that's real that
it actually is happening i had the idea
first right here you heard it i did hear
it i did hear it no at first i didn't
hear it but now i hear it
who's doing it i i see it all the time
on instagram maybe the island boys the
island
by the way i don't want to get i don't i
don't know this is going to be an adhd
episode but i am full on board with the
island boys me too i went on a deep dive
on the tiki takis yeah and i watched
like they they answer questions fan
questions right i watch like no joke
maybe a hundred of them and i guess my
nose is so fly soldier yeah yeah fly
soldier
i like his i like his demeanor now who's
fly soldier he's the one with the 17.
god it's the
eagle is i think something red or have
you but fly soldiers plays good music
now that now the island boys first of
all we're the staten island boys yeah we
just stand in islands
nice kids we're gonna get them on we're
gonna get them on the pod the island
boys will come on the pod at the very
least via zoom yeah um
christian sal you're the island baby
i say christensen you're the island
babies love it by the way the prompt i
gave them for that cameo
i wrote uh chris and saller are a couple
friends i have who love to dance alone
and they're in the closet until their
dad dies nice
nice nice we're we're friends but both
of our dads we're in the closets of both
of our dads
um
so so i mean absolutely hammered at the
knicks game then we go to pizzeria
suprema which is right across chief matt
square garden if you're not from new
york and you're coming to new york which
by the way you should be coming new york
now tourism is back open everything's
back up in new york city come on back
msg right across the street there's one
of the best pizzerias i think in the
city it's called pizzeria supremo or
pizzeria soprema for the
spanish-speaking audience yeah yeah
there was a knife fight in there a week
ago so it's getting great like literally
blood on the streets blood everywhere i
have the video like a full knife one
some guy got his hand cut off oh so so
if you love pizza get there right away
get there right away yeah because i
don't know what was i don't know if they
were fighting because they ran out of
pepperoni i have no idea what happened
sure but there was a big knife where
there was still blood on the streets but
you witnessed it no we saw it but it
happened two days before we went in so
there were still little blood spatches
on the street in daylight on the cement
in the daylight but we went but you know
i went to the pizza
we had to go get pizza because i said
pimp i gotta sober up i can't go home
this drunk right so i have to sober up
so i ate two two maybe three slices of
pizza who knows who's counting at that
time
it was 9 30 at night yeah who's counting
so everyone knows you don't count after
8 pm you can't count up my fitness pal
shuts off by the way i'm back on my
fitness pal i want to announce to the
group and to the podcast listeners i
have finally taken the plunge and i am
back on my fitness pal i have 300
calories left for the day
okay
not bad not bad but to get but it's it's
it's it's 1 pm to get to 1300 calories
i'm going to have to go to sleep go down
early yeah yeah or i'm going to have to
eat a bunch of vegetables are you
allowed to input on a fitness app msg
nick scheme and it just populates seven
thousand calories yeah just
i i probably well no we did good eating
the food we had salmon and vegetables
but then really yeah food is where i'm
like oh let me go off queen we did well
we did we did go off you go in that room
and it's like the three tables yeah
and we went wild yeah so we so we we did
go off we did go off queen somewhat yeah
but we kind i mean i had when pimp went
to the bathroom i had three cookies so i
went off a little bit pimp
saw him sneak in the cookie and then
pretend he had sushi on his plate yeah
he's eating a cookie with a chopstick
real quick yeah so i did go off a little
bit so i was at my cali i was at my
caloric limit entering the knicks game
and i definitely went over it but then
after because i didn't realize putting
my i put uh vodka sodas into my fitness
pal app they're like 160 calories a
drink
no
it said vodka club soda 160 should be
about 70.
70 calories club soda zero a shot one
ounce of vodka is probably about 70
calories maybe thinking you're putting
two shots of vodka in it oh are they
hitting you with the doubles at the next
game no they wouldn't do that i don't
know james dolan doesn't do that by the
way you're skipping my favorite part
chris got so hammered he started trying
to guess the weight of some kid who was
sitting next to us like abusing this kid
yeah he started he walked past me to get
to my seat and he walked past i said i
said what do you weigh about 170. he was
like 175 i said you're fat
you know yeah and he was like what and i
was like i'm just kidding he's in the
box yeah i was like i'm just kidding i'm
drunk and then you you sat in the sweet
not down on the floor no we sat on the
floor no we sat on the floor you were in
the suite no but you know you go up to
the suite to get the food you're just in
the right 200 suite and then you know
they bring you down and we go you
no they didn't throw me on the camera i
i was like because we were like you know
there was court sign and then we were
one row back so sometimes i don't know
sometimes
but as a matter of fact i'm happy to go
on the cam this time because yeah fat
joe uh uh trey songz uh uh steve sharipa
you got all these big new york
characters i'm like i i don't want to i
don't need you
right yeah i was like i don't need the
fat joe and you know fat joe i was like
i don't need to bomb on the jumbotron
right now facto sat next to me when i
went last time he's the best fat joe
that's the best number one shout out
rodrick shout out facto shout out matt
shout out mount your brother i saw a
clip of fat show after the game you went
to you know uh uh what's his name uh
uh uh
uh bagel uh he raps on the streets yeah
yeah what's his name i'm forgetting like
kills like he's a known like new york
guy
like that killer
walk right past him we're like we love
this guy and then we were drunk picked
up his mic instead of freestyling and we
were that must have happened literally
i'm not lying 10 seconds after we left
because he was in the elevator behind us
fat joe and we were online drunk eating
pizza and then he does a huge free a new
york freestyle yeah check this out this
is awesome to see well i'm sorry sorry
i'm i'm skipping on his name it's like
killer
let's get his name yeah click click the
video or you could go to what is new
york instagram if this doesn't have it
um but it should have it yeah the moment
when rap in new york city and nor'easter
[Music]
yeah this kid is rapping in the pouring
rain he's great he's here all the time
right
[Music]
then he just walks away
[Music]
you know and then he just skipped that
shirt what's his shirt say
i gotta remember this guy yeah because
people like because i i re i posted it
and people were messaging me that's my
boy blah blah blah i forgot his name if
you go to what is new york i think they
tagged him too what is new york here we
go kosher dills kosher damn kosher dill
shout out kosher dills go check him out
on instagram
awesome guy uh get stands out there with
um that's what that he's he's that's
like new york right there that's new
york that guy commits he's out there all
the time he becomes someone just by
doing what he does yeah and that gets
attached to new york's dna i gotta give
a big shout out to coach yeah and fat
joe gave him 20 bucks so shout out to
you really that's what that's what
kosher does says yeah cool just to go
back to the court side so the guy chris
is abusing about his weight his friend
is definitely someone very famous yeah
we don't know who he was though the way
he was avoiding chris i could tell he
was famous but chris was just trolling
him on laying on his lap at one point
making fun of his cowboy boots yeah i
kept abusing him cause he said he had
cowboy boots i was struck by the third
quarter
no cell by the third quarter it was
lights out how many did you have i was
blackout i was blackout chris you're not
afraid of getting uh your your your uh
your uh you know your good good will
there reneged when i'm drunk like that i
all cautions to the winner i don't care
about anything i texted i texted the man
who gave us the tickets i i deeply
apologize for what he said everyone said
you were a ball of fun i said okay thank
god okay because so so he um so so i
lean in with those guys i take pictures
of both of them only one of them gave me
the instagram they're like i want to get
my instagram i said follow these guys on
grindr and then i put their instagram
and i tag grinder and then grind or
repost it no so that was problematic no
um yeah but then
i think chris kept yelling at the
celebrity he didn't want to talk to him
he kept telling him one of those guys
[ __ ] my high school girlfriend yeah
one of those because one of the players
on the knicks hooked up with my high
school girlfriend so i kept yelling i
kept yelling dad he would hit a shot
this guy and i beg you bang my high
school girlfriend how was it no how was
it i was i would go you ruined me i was
yo you ruined me i should have cancelled
my five spots no dude we had so but then
yeah i don't
we need to go together because i think
that now you know
first of all because i think if you
because we could go together we could
get four you could get your two through
your guy
it's probably the same guy my two threw
my guy and then four of us can go you
know you can go you could pick up maybe
you bring derozan i bring pimp and we
just go up and we do no pressure that's
fine and we both go yeah you know unless
unless he gives you more than two i
always only get i'm always just a plus
one two usually usually two what's this
look like i think it looks phenomenal
okay i think
so okay so let me tell you about let me
tell you about the 24 hours i had so i
wake up you know 6 a.m
when i wake up when and i know i'm gonna
be i'm gonna be
i would walk 500 miles and
da
so you woke up shout out tom brady
congratulations on winning that super
bowl again baby did you see what
happened to 600
uh
touchdown ball
before i get that i just want to shout
out uh i've been remiss if i didn't
mention my homes go ahead he's got bus
patrick shot at patchwork kansas city
chief suck this year you're having a
yeah you're in a bad way but you got to
turn it around
december 29th that's right go ahead uh
brady throws a 600 bull to mike evans
yes mike evans doesn't realize it gives
it to a fan
the organization comes out immediately
goes up to the fan in the first row and
it's like we need this thing back the
guy's saying i don't know if i want to
give it back they're like we'll sweeten
the pot for you okay
we will give you this is this what they
gave him we will give you a tom brady
autographed jersey okay tom brady's
helmet
mike evans autographed jersey mike evans
is uh game worn cleats from that day
okay a thousand dollars for the store
inside for the tampa bucks like super
like the store
free tickets to every game for the rest
of the season and the entire next season
okay okay and i think that's it the guy
takes it
i was like oh that's not that bad i
guess but it's
it's it's i guess 30 pairs of tickets
yeah a thousand dollar credit
brady's signed jersey and helmet awesome
look brady comes out okay please go
please no she's gonna say estimated
value if we're on if i know i know what
the estimated value is what is it i'm
gonna hold okay hold hold go ahead brady
comes out says
publicly i think he should have held out
a little longer yeah oh and uh here we
go thanks babes
and then and then
brady's feels bad gives him a bitcoin
gives him a bitcoin 63 000 bitcoin wow
give me a bitcoin then gronk
and mojo rawley from wwe you are friends
they are like
they are doing like uh uh
they're they're attaching themselves to
a crypt new cryptocurrency and so i
guess for promotion slash also helping
the guy they give him one of their 4
hundred six hundred
coins worth at forty four dollars a week
for thirty one thousand
so now the guys got
eighty four thousand in crypto
two seasons worth of tickets the jerseys
the helmets the autographs and the
thousands in the store
for the ball i'm like whoa pretty
freaking good right the ball's worth
five hundred thousand dollars wow they
hosed him
the ball is worth five so brady and
gronk didn't give him that until he
accepted the piss-poor deal that we
thought was good ourselves and then they
gave him that and then i was like wow
that's getting eighty thousand dollars
but meanwhile it's worth a half a
million i have a million million a
million million
now what you should do in that situation
if you ever find yourself in this
situation where you're catching a a tom
brady historic touchdown pass what you
need to do is is honestly what i think
you personally do even though it may
feel uncomfortable yeah what you need to
do is leave the stadium immediately with
the ball that is you have rightfully so
possessed yes and then leave the stadium
speak legally give them your information
yeah call me and then we will talk about
what to do because you would have gotten
potentially 750 life-changing it would
have been life-changing you got to play
the game man what do that's what their
agents do honestly yes i bet you i bet
you if he would have done that yeah he
would have even gotten more from brady
and everyone because they would be like
i respect this guy he would have went on
he would have been a legend he's on
barcelona nobody respects him now no
they're like you idiot his wife divorced
him yeah
what about mike evans course brady
seventy girl like another kid i know
that was funny when you see that clip of
like the staff going on him like that
was his 600 ball he was like oh no i'm
short i bet you though tom do you think
tom brady actually cares after 600
touchdowns do you think he genuinely
even gets that ball back
i don't even know if tom's the kind of
guy who would care i call him tom like i
know him i apologize i deeply apologize
for that mr brady tb how about this i
stole a line from hey baby tom brady tb
tampa bay tempe bucks
tuberculosis what you what i thought you
had in the beginning of the episode
that's right pimp salads are here pimp
salads are here pimps pimps by the way
i gotta add something to pimp's workout
regime pamp has been lost 50 plus pounds
now his workout regiment
regimen i'm gonna say out regime because
he's doing
they're really doing nasty things he's
yeah
he's in a world workout
he's under he's honestly the cia is
watching him now because the workout
regime that he's creating it's not
necessarily legal and it could lead to
bad things
it's nothing right now but you got
regime or workout regimen
uh regime
so
salads all he eats salads which he's
eating right now drinks heinekens and
eats magic spoon cereal that's all he
does that's all he does that's all he
does where have they been are they still
with you they're still with me he's
still over on the couch are they still
with us with hey babe yeah i think
they're coming we haven't done an ms in
a while use the promo code hey babe see
what happens yeah yeah try it it's not
um yeah i could go for another four
boxes that if you're watching magic
spooner we know that you are cookies and
cream dude there was a hole in the
marketplace and somebody filled this
hole
true bill
is this company that's with us now and
this is an app is it right yes this is
an app it's the most genius thing i've
ever heard this should have been on
shark tank it's the new app that helps
you identify and stop paying for
subscriptions you don't need want or
simply forgot about whoever bill is
yeah bill if you're watching and we know
that you are what a great company
because i imagine it's it's named after
a guy named bill true bill true bill
yeah yeah true bill what happens is they
let you know when stuff automatically
renews and if you don't want it you just
hit one button they keep track of
everything they aggregate you'll link it
to your account and true bill will
cancel your unwanted subscriptions in
one single tap on average people are
saving 720 beans a year with true bill
you get a true bill concierge they're
there when you need them to cancel
unwanted subscriptions and it's crazy
i'll use this and i've gotten two or
three subscriptions canceled and my
concierge names coincidentally is named
bill bill yeah so it's just a true bill
he said i get all the time he's like i'm
not the bill from true but i am my name
is bill and i do work for troops for
real for real they've already got two
million can you scroll up one second
they two million users already yes they
saved over a hundred million dollars and
that's a lot of money anyway don't fall
for subscriptions camps i love this i'm
gonna start using it immediately start
canceling today at truebuild.com
hey babe
go right now truebill.com hey babe it
could save you thousands a year
truebuild.com hey babe don't cancel your
subscription hey babe though dude amazon
music i love it you love it we both have
it well i love music and i love amazon
shame with me so you comments on forest
yeah i love that too i love amazon women
dude you know what all the other places
only have you know 9.5 million podcasts
amazon has 10 million podcasts free free
10 million free podcasts hilarious
podcasts yeah like like hey babe like
a true crime podcast like dr death
miracle man well smart less is a
hilarious one i haven't watched it but
now you've got my interest and it's
ad-free which we love ad-free this is an
ad but it's not just for pockets
yeah if you don't want to see us go over
to amazon music please um no but they
also have thousands of music stations
top playlists for free the best uh you
can go hands-free with alexa and do it
yeah if you like me and you want your
music on demand and ad-free go to amazon
music unlimited they give you access to
over 75 million songs it'll take you
weeks to listen to that weeks weeks
weeks and you can get a sweet discount
right now if you just go to amazon.com
hey babe that's amazon.com hey bade hey
babe unlimited free for three months so
if you just put in the promo code you
get it for free i don't know why now's
the time it's just for a limited time
new customers do it unlimited free for
three months
and uh amazon.com and renews
automatically though cancel any time
terms apply absolutely jeff bezos
he knows what he's doing he knows what
he's doing yeah speaking of watch no
that watch you know what you are
i
pulled i pulled some hey babe stunts
on the wendy williams show
which was co-hosted by whitney cummings
that i did oh i didn't know that she was
the co-host for the day or if she said
no wendy williams in the hot wendy
williams is something she's something's
going on wait a minute wait a minute
yeah you went on the wendy williams show
you didn't know when he was your host
wendy williams no i was caused by what i
thought you bombed because it was wendy
williams now that i know that whitney
cummings was the co-host how could you
possibly bomb
you're friends with her and she's a
comment no whitney cummings was laughing
and have a good time we're comics having
fun but the audience was was not having
it oh this is amazing so i saw it online
and i didn't watch it just so for our
hey babes that we could watch it
together right okay so let me preface
with this i let me let me preface all of
this with
what you're about to see i am still
actively drunk from the knicks game the
night before
a car picked me up at six o'clock in the
morning homeless pimp drove my children
to school that morning because i
couldn't i could not i was so let me
just just we're gonna get we get home
from the next game finally i say to pimp
go outside my door because pimp stays
over i said do not make a sound the kids
are sleeping jasmine's sleeping she'll
be pissed waking up the baby whatever
pimp so you won't even hear me i'll be
like a mouse
pimp goes in starts brushing his teeth i
go to put i put my wallet and my keys in
my little bowl that i have right by the
door take one step fall over boxes that
were on the floor whole body on the
floor shake the room
baby within three two one
jasmine turns the light on she goes
don't even think about coming up here
sleep in the basement so i was like i
deserve this
delilah wakes up my little daughter
wakes up i almost set the [ __ ] alarm
off hammered fall on the floor then i
proceeded because i was drunk i was his
sow hysterical laughing on the floor
pimp's dying laughing brushing his teeth
i go into the kitchen i see a bowl a pot
of tortellini and string beans i proceed
to eat the entire part of it with my
hands eating it with my answers it felt
so good i had all my face fall asleep in
my clothes right wake up to 6 a.m 6 a.m
car picking me up i'm still actively
drunk i wake up jasmine's up she goes
what happened to the tortellini last
time i said i ate it with my hands she
goes that was lunch for the kids you
[ __ ] oh i was like
i was like i gotta go do the wendy
williams show she was like don't come
back
oh my god that drone so i get into the
car by the way these were the cl that's
what i wore to the knicks game i get
into the car oh yeah we got the proof no
yeah yeah this is what i did i threw
watermelon and take a shower whitney
comes she goes oh you stink you smell
like alcohol i was like do you have any
it's like hair or the dog but she goes
she goes chris it's nine o'clock in the
morning i was like what can you do so so
i go so i go get to first of all in the
car ride there in the car right there i
am farting like you can't believe where
the guy the driver was actually laughing
he kept on he kept closing he goes this
is so bad audibly or he just smelled you
smelled them and
you couldn't hide it so and he had like
a barrier up like a plastic barrier that
you could unzip and i just kept saying
i'm so sorry
oh no just tortellini string bean pizza
sushi cookie you know vodka soda farts
gross i feel awesome i go to him i go to
buddy i i had such a addict i said do
you have advil he goes yes i do so gives
me to advil thank god
he literally by the way i want to shout
out the driver of this of this uh
company i don't know what it is the
wendy wolves the best guy ever i say to
him we were running late because i got
out of the house a little bit late i go
oh my god we're so late i go i need
coffee so much she goes i have a coffee
that i haven't drank it it still had the
starbucks sword in it
i swear to god he goes do you want it i
said are you kidding me
lifesaver literally in a drunk stupor
right then and there i i give him a
hundred bucks
yeah he goes sir you don't have to do
that i see you take it you're a hero
absolutely you take it so i paid 100
bucks for a cup of starbucks from i
think his name was jose shout out jose
um
drink the coffee i'm now i'm feeling
good coffee helps grow ups the headaches
going away yeah i walk in
and you know i'm disheveled
as soon as i walk in
shout out to producer very nice man very
gay gentleman comes in takes me goes oh
honey you need hair and makeup
so i said
yeah
so i said yes i do my friend and i'm
still actively drunk i'm starting
m m's you know little granola bars i
mean all the snacks they put me in hair
and makeup
this is like when i did regis with chris
pratt and i walked out with the uh
magnificent let's do let's zoom out and
then we'll do yours like we did i've
done it already
right yeah so so so
um
i'm in there we do a rehearsal show goes
by the way this was the only episode
that whitney did live
live no edits live 100 live it's aired
live live at 10 a.m not live not not not
live to tape no no live what you were if
it was 1001 it was 10 001 oh fully live
i didn't know that
whitney it was even news to whitney at
rehearsal they were like oh this is live
she didn't even know at rehearsal so now
at rehearsal we're supposed to do all
the jokes whatever i can't even think
straight i like can't even think were
you just joining the panel are you doing
stand up or what no i was joining the
panel was called hot talk it was me
whitney cummings michelle buteau and
crystal smith so three female like
empowerment comedians and piece of [ __ ]
chris is definitely okay so so i
so i go on there at rehearsal literally
at rehearsal i started falling asleep in
the middle of rehearsal and they were
like what is going on oh my god so now
it's 10 a.m i'm feeling good the guy the
staff actually you know before this
really liked me like they were being so
nice that the gay guy was being like oh
you are such a riot i love you honey
after what you're about to see the bomb
nobody nobody taught didn't even walk me
down to my car they said the elevator
take it to the right i cannot wait
two were you on the whole app or i was
on for 20 minutes okay the people have
since said oh it's not that bad of a
bomb but as a comic i mean taking swings
and in the moment
i start on live i start this episode the
first time they talk to me i actually
make a joke i'm like it's lovely to be
here with you lovely ladies you're all
beautiful women and then i make an an
immediate u-turn for no reason i just
yell i love fat people and then starts
to go downhill let's take a look
oh my god
[Applause]
oh god you do not fit in
at the durham performing arts center in
durham north carolina give it up for
comedian chris
oh my god you look drunk i'm fully drunk
flip flops
actress rebel she's frustrated with the
public's obsession with her body okay so
they're talking about rebel wilson and
body image
that's a good joke you're exciting with
the body yeah
um
i
i mean yeah it does make sense i mean
it's not it's not imaginary to say that
we don't like the fat focus right this
is like you're on the view yeah yeah
exactly fat phobia girl power like
retaliate being in your stomach that's
how i know they tell me i'm listening
look at you look at you look at you i'm
zoned out you're zoned out i'm
legitimately actively drunk
if they come for your body do you feel
like you might throw up at all hundred
percent worse like your movies are great
i'm just shaking my head i'm not
listening to anything whitney saying
i look i don't even know who rebel
wilson is shout out sort of like the hot
girl the it girl the number one in the
show you're the best friend you're the
character actor so now you know she
knows shelby told good comedian for
herself being the hot girl
it's all clapping stuff right all they
do is clap so it's a weird thing when
people start talking about your way in a
new way because you have a problem i get
them on my side here and
i'm getting fat now i put on about 25
pounds i got a nice puffy here's the
first box once again which is nice to
see oh um
i'm going to be one of those guys like
there's no way i'm going to have two
feet when i'm 50. zero bump i'm gonna
get one cut off and i just love her yeah
there's a floyd
i think she's great big rom-com guy i'm
big rom-com guys but guys don't really
get it right like if a guy gains weight
it's just like wow he's so distinguished
yeah i'm starting to get yelled at all
right hills
is like the only man that spoke out and
stood up and he's just like please do
not talk about my way i'm like can we
all do that then yeah can we all just
say that yeah yeah i mean the one thing
i will say is that if you're famous your
your marriage is going to be scrutinized
they
to do the bit they had to put him down
they they clearly went and searched the
worst one of them ever to put up next to
him so you can see the difference but
they're doing what they're talking about
right yeah they're exactly doing it
right they're like yeah all right
scrutinize your weight's gonna be
scrutinized your kids are gonna be
screwed it might be worth it just watch
you know cause i mean yeah the bombs
they keep coming and they're coming hard
and i think that when they start
attacking the audience it usually means
they can't come for anything else
and when someone calls you like you know
it's too skinny or too ugly it means
they can't say you're not funny or not
see it's all points everybody just claps
at points
that's all it is yes
that's what i was on
a yes queen panel
yes
it's petty yeah yeah exactly i don't
know why you guys would have a man on
this panel this is the worst idea ever
because i okay say anything i say the
audience is going to hate honesty so i
just but i i love here's the thing i i
know uh the mother of your two children
and uh if if you can handle her you can
handle the three of us oh yes i was
beaten this morning right now i do a
joke
don't reference that she's puerto rican
i do a puerto rican taylor joke without
ever explaining that she's puerto rican
kid's mother uh jasmine i was like i was
terrified of her she dropped her name on
them what can you do and what did you
say if uh if women want to dm you um on
instagram what did she i forgot what you
were just like don't d i mean she's
checking them she checks oh yeah yeah no
no no no she says she's not here but
she's here right now
i can smell the adobo i know she's here
bob so like what is he talking about is
he just closed proximity to three
beautiful women
look at michelle's face is like what is
it what does it even mean to anyone i
could smell
that she's a puerto rican woman
it just it just sounds like you have a
smelly wife yeah yeah just bombing it
smells like you just have a wife that
smells like seasonings here's here's a
big bomb coming up on on topic two which
i start off
yeah
see now it's all points clapping at
points here
i'm getting i'm getting yelled at your
face you have a smirk on
yeah look
your skin is crawling look you're
actually you are drunk you're making
like drunk faces no i'm drunk
it's so funny you're like definitely
like you probably didn't know that like
the camera's on you most of the time
yeah because you're you're like not
poised at all no no i'm not you're
fidgety yeah you're squinting you're
smiling you're leaning back and forth
yeah you see your brain going when
you're fully drunk
a new tattoo of courtney's lips and a
scorpion
i mean look i would never i literally
i would never get a tattoo
uh i would get them on my dogs so if any
of you guys are named daisy
right here
three two one i would never tell you a
man's name there's also no way that that
was travis barker's idea to get the
tattoo covered up that was his wife made
him do that she was like you're not
going to marry me and i have another
woman's name on your body i know that
from being a relationship no it's not
going to happen he if i was travis
barker travis
if you're watching and i know that you
well
right now and make sure that there are
no other tattoos of any other women on
your body because it's not going to be
cover-up next time she's going to start
amputating body parts and you're going
to come out to your next concert looking
like a civil war veteran so you really
need to
zero bomb
oh my god it gets worse
oh my god it's so good i ended on a q a
joke oh let's go
that was that was the best joke of the
whole segment so far
see
see and now it's just making a lot of
yes yes it's a lot of y'all and i start
i yell that at them i go yeah let's just
clap at points
i was like angry yeah look look
you're so healthy
you're so mentally also my whole thing
is the marriage is over why would i
still keep my name on you
it's the girl on the right of comics
yeah
so why aren't they like why aren't they
playing off yet diffic feels about this
tattoo
if we gotta talk about who has feelings
but here's how you feeling about it
drinking the waters
because i was hung over someone saw an
apprentice still drunk put a ring on it
that's what you do when you love someone
i also do not want a man tattooed
on his body because they grow body hair
so i invented
the podcast with he has dolly parton
who's who's her gay co-host who nobody
knows that they're his gay co-hosts
then i yell bent into my beard
i yelled bent it's
i need a deposit for the house we're
gonna live in that's right that's what i
want cause the tattoo don't attach it's
not gonna pay the bills that's cute a
tattoo is not gonna put gas in my car
okay megan the stallion is facing
criticism after refusing to freestyle on
megan
i was going to say i'm chrissy the pony
and i forgot
you're the artist that's great
like you'd always be expected to perform
when asked no no she paid her dues she's
amazing she's doing her thing let's let
this woman live let her walk into
whatever event she needs to walk into
without feeling like she's got a tap
dance right now i'll tell you what
here's here's the most brutal joke of
them all my knees hurt from tap dancing
take the tap shoes back i want to sit
down relax you call it stand up comedy
i'm gonna sit down and do comedy i'm
tired y'all stop asking us to do stuff
okay there's also like she needs her too
but
what did you say ten years in comedy
whitney's needs her too but oh
michelle on the other comic's face
it's the perfect freestyle look at
whitney's face yeah she's a good spoiler
no whitney's a great comic she gets it
no i'm saying she does that's what she's
living and the other the the audience
bomb i mean bombing oh my god oh that's
so yeah here we go it's got what two
more minutes like that what'd you say
for the for the audience you said
whitney's been on her knees too i said
what i said to michelle butoh says my
knees hurt from you know from being ten
years in comedy trying to tap dance
around these executives or whatever and
i said whitney's knees hurt from ten
years being in comedy too but it's not
from dancing
and it's daytime tv
tv
on the show
i love it
i love it
because i keep forgetting it's daytime
tv not our podcast everybody watching we
have podcasts and you can talk for like
three hours and say whatever you want we
have 10 minutes and we're not allowed to
say anything
like i'm gonna lose my career
the number of but he's about his career
is about to be over you will not be
seeing him at the durham theater uh
whatever that was this is a shane
situation
it's a shameful situation shane gillis
situation no she didn't say that she
said
why
why that's just it's off the rails the
show's off the [ __ ] round they even
know shane gillis isn't no they have no
idea the wendy williams audience the
wendy williams had no clue what was
going on can we make this a regular
thing where we just troll morning tv
which podcasts inside jokes yes
november 13th there you go if you want
to come to my show instead
look at the way she looked at me you
could come to my show
that's all it is it's just clapping
clap at point i said let's clap that
point
yeah so let's clap at points you [ __ ]
idiots
yeah
that's half the comedy specials today
anyway yeah
like yeah tell me a joke right here we
go are you funny or what kind of comedy
do you think also what's your stick
what's your stick but funny but people
also she just walked in she was coming
in to the place and the guy was running
up on her with the mic and he's going
hey how you doing you happy to be here
at the racetrack you got to rap for the
racetrack rap about cars
yeah and then she just politely said no
thank you i don't have a wrap and kept
walking yeah it's like you can't afford
my fee i cannot afford myself but i it
happens to all the time guys will do it
a lot especially like on dates and stuff
like oh you're you're funny tell me joke
make me laugh i'm like make me laugh
take your pants off oh boom there we go
daytime whitney
she got that she got she got a laugh and
an applause break for that of course
i yelled i have warts
i just yelled i have warts and started
clapping i was fully drunk
did she say i would have told that joke
differently to you i don't know what she
who she was talking to
can you rewind a second
[Applause]
[Laughter]
i can't believe you just said that on
the wedding
but look she goes i would have told that
differently
oh she said it yeah you also went i'm
six i'm seven with one
viral for having 21 babies and 16 live
in nannies
this is wild she and her own millionaire
husband of course paid 195 000 to
surrogates between march of last year
and july this year okay she's doing a
lot of it via surrogate crystal why why
would anyone do this yeah that's a lot
of kids it's too many kids
with 16 surrogates why are you
collecting that many babies like pokemon
and i read the i read in fairness she's
bombing too
that's
they're all 18 months 16 months why why
would you choose to put your life on the
hardest mode possible right
you know i mean as
uh someone who has um had a surrogate
for my two and a half year old twins
hazel and otis i think this is just
really gross there are other people who
also want to have a family and she's
just out here just you know i you know i
think this is just really wrong i think
this is
uh yeah
it should be like you know how you have
too many kittens and like yeah
somebody's gotta come in and be like you
have too much like i think so much
yes my you know girlfriend entire family
you know puerto rican my kids puerto
ricans so like abuelita at home she has
like 26 grandkids no nannies so i think
that's what my family is like why does
this woman have 16 nannies for 21 kids
and you don't need that that's a one
name so funny again
you got nothing the crowd hates you
oh i got a little laugh
look at that my
podcast the time francie chaos also how
boring are you that you have this many
kids and you don't have a reality show
yeah
i have more questions how bad is your
personality i i have more questions
about this because why did you want this
many kids this fast
why
and then if you did want these kids she
said i read the article and said she
spends ninety six thousand dollars on
the nannies alone wow
just on the nannies maybe 100
maybe she just loved charlie and the
chocolate factory then i ended up joke
here no look at how michelle looks at me
do you know michelle yeah kind of right
so she knows what you're doing yeah so
after this she looks you but after that
afterwards did she did you know
she called me she left me a voicemail
and said hey if you want to talk about
what happened today i'm all ears i'm a
friend what oh yeah i have the voice oh
yeah no no she fully called me and said
do you want to talk about what happened
today i'm here
oh because it just was in her eyes it's
a travesty i guess
oh my god so
that's hysterical very very lonely i'm
very very lonely here's the last last
joke and then it's over
q and on i end on q and on and bomb so
like
21 babies i thought they were all
different ages but they're all babies
what i just what's the point it just
that's that looks like diapers
it just looks like it smells like diet
no that looks like a q anon conspiracy
waiting to happen that looks like that
looks like my dermatologist's office
when i go to the meetings later i'll
find out
thank you guys so
much gonna pass out
now look at michelle look there's a hand
in her face look look at her looking at
me
[Laughter]
i love you in a dance this feels like a
sketch yeah this is real that's daytime
question oh my god i mean
seven jokes six out of seven bombs oh
when i go to the meetings later
yeah and then you see the way she looked
at him
i mean why does it look like her
dermatologist i didn't get that i didn't
get that joke what does she mean with a
dermatologist maybe stay-at-home moms go
to doctors i don't know what happens
right i don't even know what it means
like it looks like a queuing on me maybe
like kids on your face like i don't
understand i don't know i mean she had
to say something yeah right the people
are gonna clap regardless
i think it's a come on my skin joke
like dermatologist like i got 21 kids on
my skin i think it could be that
no that's like that's a few leaps to get
to that i think i think i'm just missing
and she probably i'm probably ignorant
about something what's up everybody want
to talk to you about butcher box one of
our sponsors uh me and chris used
butcher box we love it uh high quality
meat delivered right to our door
ethically sustainably and it tastes
better because i know that
they're doing the right thing
um
i
get a delivery every couple of months
and i change what i want i customize the
box it's really cool i just go online
and just choose the the quality uh the
cuts of meat that i want uh i tell you
right now i don't have to go shopping
for one thing i hate doing is going
shopping for beef
that's the thing of the past now okay
and also the cost is better and the
quality is just as good there are no
antibiotics and no hormones each box
contains 8 to 14 pounds of meat
depending on the box you choose it's
enough for 24 individual meals you can
customize your own box which i do with
one of theirs or choose a pre-planned
box either way you get exactly what you
want this holiday butcher box is proud
to give new members
free new york strip steaks for a year
this deal has never been offered before
and it won't last forever that sounds
crazy get two delicious 100 grass-fed
new york strip sticks for free in every
box for a year offer is only available
till november 30th 21 so get it before
it's gone go just go to butcherbox.com
hey babe to sign up that's
butcherbox.com hey babe to receive this
limited time offer of free new york
strip steaks for a year butch butcherbox
what's up everybody want to talk to you
about draftkings draftkings uh i
actually started playing draftkings
this
this football season it just makes my
football sundays a little better i
usually play fantasy football but i
wanted some side action so i started
using it i have the app it's really easy
and convenient uh this thanksgiving be
thankful for your family your food and
your free bets that's right draftking
sportsbook and official sports betting
partner of the nfl has a turkey day no
brainer you can't miss new customers can
uh can bet just one dollar on any
thanksgiving nfl game and win 100 in
free bets if either team scores a point
if sportsbook isn't available in your
state yet you can still get in on that
thanksgiving nfl action
make your first deposit and you can play
for free
uh for millions with draftkings daily
fantasy football contest draftkings is
safe secure reliable best of all you can
deposit the majority of cash whenever
you want that's a big one you don't have
to wait around for people to pay you
which i've been doing my whole life
download the draftking sports book app
now use promo code hey babe bet just one
dollar on any thanksgiving nfl game and
win 100 in free bets if either team
scores a point that's a pretty good deal
they're probably going to score a point
that's promo code hey babe this
thanksgiving at draftkings sportsbook an
official sports wedding partner of the
nfl
must be 21 years old or older
new jersey
indiana
or pennsylvania only not sure what that
means i think you have to be 21 in those
states i don't know i'm just reading
what they tell me new customers only
restrictions apply see draftkings.com
sportsbook for details gambling problem
that's no good
then don't do this if you have a game
problem you're going to want to call
1-800 gambler draftkings check it out so
then after that so then after that after
this i mean full bomb you know nobody
lit literally nobody you walked off and
had to walk your way to the hallway the
people who were so nice to me they were
like no you know mostly gay staff they
were like no honey even i even emailed
the guy to get to get um you know the
clips for the show i said hey you know
so great meeting do you have any clips
for the show i'd love to promote my own
social media and he just uh cc's another
person's like um from now on you'll be
dealing with this person and then
she runs the social media so
did uh did anyone weigh in over like you
did what did they think it was funny
they went to uca no no no nobody really
saw it i tweeted out the link i tweeted
i just bombed on the wendy williams show
please send video and then people
started weighing in on it okay you know
um
but then after that i get right in the
car with my man jose get right in the
car and we go up to the beacon theater
um which i'm doing february 5th by the
way big new york city show beacon
theater
get the tickets christy comedy.com on
sale new york city beacon theater we go
to shoot the promo for it we go to the
diner i see tt jerry
and homeless pam homeless films having a
bowl of oatmeal tt jerry's eating a
cream cheese bagel she's wearing tt
jerry's wearing the dress the dress that
i conceived delilah in she took
jasmine's dress jasmine's dress that the
night delilah seven years ago was
conceived in a zip-up dress which zipped
from head to toe with jasmine looked so
hot and then we could see the baby
jerry was wearing no tj is wearing the
dress and you could see the promos that
you're that are a lot must be live now
on them they're live now for the beacon
theater um this is what yeah look this
is the dress that i like that delilah
could see that tt jerry stole from
jasmine's closet
and was on a diner in the upper west
side around all jewish people that
didn't know what the [ __ ] to do oh my
goodness yeah
so and then we filmed promos all day um
and uh it's amazing to see titi in uh a
low-cut dress with her hair done her
makeup on but then sometimes she'll come
out like a sports coat she'll have a
goatee with a goatee and a hair an
opponent yeah she's i told her to dress
like a woman she nails both looks she's
good with both she's hot as both genders
i don't know she's hot as both genders
from the back you don't know like if tt
was turning around looking out the
window i would you can't really tell her
and jasmine apart from the back
no disrespect
yeah um but yeah so that was and i i
swear to god dude i was drunk for almost
24 hours because then got back had some
more drinks whatever i'm this was two
days ago i'm fully sober now but i did
wake up with remnants of the hangover
this morning and then i forced you to do
edibles on your patreon and i did
edibles on the patreon dude when you
leave me
you go off the rails i'm going to have
to go right now you don't drink or just
do anything with me i'm running on
dunkin wow no dude it's it's been bad i
have to clean up my act i can't because
now because one of those things when i
would go to the doctor and they would
say how many alcoholic drinks do you
have a week i'd say
two three like i'm not a drinker but now
it's like 25. now it's like i have to be
like okay wow we're getting into the
territory now where it slowly again not
getting like running ossified but it's
like six monday five wednesday sixth
saturday yeah you know what i mean now
we're getting up there yeah i stopped
doing them when i do spots i stopped
drinking so you don't drink it all when
you go do something most i'll do is one
drink and i'll nurse it through like as
much as i can so when you did the stand
the other night when you had three spots
i had a water wow so when are you
drinking
um well you're just tailing paper and
off not really
i mean you know maybe if we have people
over or something like that right so
have there been what's the most amount
of weeks you've won in a row recently
without taking a sip of alcohol or most
amount of days it's probably not that
many days because like here or there
i'll have a glass of wine sometimes
we'll have a beer on the podca like it's
not like that but it's like i haven't uh
like really tied one on in a little
while since the first time you've ever
had a sip when's the first time you had
a sip of alcohol
or drank it's not like little kid dad
letting you take a sip the first time
you actually actively drank 15 16. uh i
was i was uh
17 18. so like that i went out and like
got like drank at a bar so let's say
since the time you've been 18 do you
think from 18 to your age right now
today there has been
at one week where you haven't sipped at
least a sip of alcohol oh yeah of course
so you think you've went months at times
without taking a sip yeah really yeah
yeah why just just it happened that way
or were you trying to not drink no i
think it just happened that way you know
i never really got that heavy into
drinking i mean no but i'm saying even
if you have a sip of wine at dinner or a
sip of beer like you said it happens
yeah but i have only started drinking
wine the last couple of years and i was
only really a social drinker i've never
in my life until like this podcast or
something like that uh or until dinner
and wine recently in my entire life i
never ever like drank in my home
never no i never cracked open a beer to
watch a game i never like yeah i made it
at night
nothing ever ever in my home sivir same
with me it's very recent what about pond
and edibles
well since i started doing those uh i
want to call it three years ago yeah i
do oh what's the longest i've gone no
i'm saying so so so you didn't start
doing pot and edibles when you were 18
19. no i didn't start until i was
started after 40. 41. 41 is the first
time you started getting into weed yeah
wow
i'm 37. i may i may get into it when i'm
42. no it just became accessible more
legal
i i don't know i i didn't have like a
drug dealer right you know like a weed
guy i didn't unders i never i've never
purchased like i never bought like
actual like weed and i didn't know how
to roll it i didn't know how to break it
up i never did that before until
recently do we dealers just get swept up
now in it being legalized they just get
swept up do they unfortunately lose
their careers now or is there a legal
round there i think that i don't know i
think that if you're someone's supplier
i think that and you're
you're
that person is loyal to you and they get
their stuff from you and it's convenient
maybe maybe they're not affected but
then again
i don't know by the way us having these
masks on is not blackface
no no okay no no okay no no no it's
batman fish it's batman face got it
that's right plus it doesn't cover the
full face right yeah i'm black and white
face if anything your bat your bad face
i'm bad face yeah not black face i also
did want to get sal's opinion on this
before we end um
this waiter was carrying 31 plates at
once
like for a bit or he just wanted to get
the play towels apparently how they do
business in this place and i just want
to know how you feel about the bottom of
uh somebody else's place absolutely
absurd it's absurd that he's doing that
unless it's like unless it's like
their thing that people come to see
but he doesn't need to do that at all
and also that should be a health
violation right there because
he's putting the bottom of plates
touching
just stacking them one on top of the
other so all the bottoms of the plates
which
you know i mean
it shouldn't be touching the food not
really i mean i guess you wash them and
they're stacked but
i don't know i i those i don't know that
guy walks through the restaurant puts it
on your table what do you say no thank
you do you send it back no no no i'm not
gonna knock anything
what if it was the top one i'll take the
top
wait so this is a bit or this is just i
don't even understand why he would put
himself through this it must just be for
a bit i hope i don't i don't know
okay okay what if they fall it's 40
meals
he does this it must be a brunch
it's terrible he looks like he's why
even do it is that are they cheering for
him they must be cheering does anyone
else work there he doesn't make any
sense
why is he putting himself through that i
mean i don't know i mean you know it
it's clearly it's in uh the restaurants
in the middle east um
they just do things a little different
in the middle east it's a whole the
regimes there are different i also want
to see if you guys know any of the new
words that were entered into the
dictionary what do you mean let's do it
d platform is a new word apparently like
they acknowledge it as a word in the
dictionary now okay oh zero day what is
i'm having you're having a bad day it's
called a zero day i can't see that but
okay zero day is a new word
i should use my bat vision
nice
nice
maybe batman is the one who started
covid you think it's possible oh my god
he never got any [ __ ] for that yeah he
didn't get anything in pr he's he he
escaped wow corona got destroyed right
corona beer what about batman corona did
take a hit didn't they of course yeah
people you know thought that that was
they were doing the coronavirus well
he's it's easier than ever for him to
fight crime now
sure people are just like ah ah yeah
stay six feet away not vaccinated
ooh black i don't know what what's that
blank check company i don't know what
that is the platform i get
uh blank check company is a special
purpose acquisition company has nothing
to do with a pre okay so it's a special
purpose acquisition
it's an ubleck isn't that a thing that
you put over a german letter
i thought i'd learned a new exclamation
from my hangover it's day three but no
it's a word for a specific type of slime
inspired by dr seuss i've been reading
dr seuss books to my kid every night
i've never heard of oobleck oh black no
i don't like that and enough for them to
put it in the ditch yeah
teraflop but my daughter can read my
daughter like reads like she reads the
books to me now and still to this day
she can she can she pronounced the word
adventurous the other night but she
calls dr seuss dr suss
she's like dr suss and i'm like do you
think he sucks
she goes dr suss first book i ever
learned to read was a dr seuss really
green eggs and ham interesting
interesting
[ __ ] classic green egg shout out him um
i just bought some dr seuss artwork did
you yeah you're gonna put it up yeah i
am
not it's a it's a sketch
it's a preliminary sketch that got
colored
before it went into a book of uh uh i
think the book or the poem or whatever
it was called all the places you'll go
it's in a ridge it it's not in a ridge
but it looks a rich wow the way they ran
it off it just looks like he it looks a
rich would you go online you go to an
actual office actually uh i went to a
gallery look i mean he has those
galleries all over and a lot of times
when you go to a a place that is a
tourist place those galleries don't have
a shop in those galleries
it's completely inflated but this was
just completely reasonably priced i just
really liked the picture and i and i
because i have an affinity to zeus
because my mom used to remember the
seusses what are you going to art
galleries
we talk to every day when are you going
art galleries i don't know calories
often really museums and art galleries
like you just take a day and you say i'm
going to the art college do you stumble
upon it both i've taken full days where
i've i've gone to like four or five art
galleries geez i was in l.a recently i
went to a couple of exhibits do you just
know where the art galleries are in new
york you can look it up and then i have
a friend uh that works in the industry
shout out chrissy you ever go to a party
in an art gallery like like a like a
drinking wine at an art gallery yeah
i've never done it yeah next time you go
okay i've done to a few of them they're
i do plus one yeah
i do it all the time what yeah i i love
going why don't i go with any of this
you're too busy getting black out of the
knicks
what about art galleries pimp all the
time i like to go out and get a few
drinks and see what people are but how
do you even know where to go well you
could go to some hoods that they're like
they're pretty common too so you could
just stroll and you could walk in
they're open to the public coven had
appointments and closures but like in
general unless it's like something
specific you could usually just walk
right in yeah i pay to go i go yeah
they're all over the city the city's
mostly art galleries and i've never been
a one and a museum i've been a museum
since i was a kid i kicked it up and not
yeah i i i i've been to a lot of museums
right even recently yeah i go to museums
so like what's the last museum you went
to in new york
uh i went to the moma a year ago and uh
for new york have i gone to another
museum in new york since then no but
i've gone to other museums and other
places and you just go show up at the
museum walk right in yeah take a shower
into a bowie thing and yeah i go right
in i went to a uh
when i was in uh australia i went to
like five
and uh i just looked up a bunch
i'm going i'm i'm making plans to go to
more actually can i come yeah you could
come home i really want to come i always
used to go but i kicked it up a notch
when i started looking for art to buy
for my home got it so i'm always on the
lookout because you know you got to
scour i don't want to just buy something
just to buy it i want it to speak to me
pimp
yeah does the van go exhibit counters
museum the vein goes where the van goes
the van goes exhibit they had in new
york on the south street seaport does
the van go where to the seaport yeah
yeah the van goes oh the van goes yeah
does the van go whoa the van gogh art
exhibit you ever go to the louvre no
wow was that oh that's france yeah i
missed that one that's gangbusters
that's gang so that's the one that's a
must-see what is the top one i mean you
saw the least the mona lisa
what's the top one in new york big and
you wait online and you can't even get
near it top one in new york number one
you got the guggenheim you got the moma
you got the met you got uh you know
natural history you know those are some
of some new york is iconic and known
because of the museums
because of some yeah a lot of people fly
to new york to go to the museums yeah
yeah never even thought about it i've
only been in central park three or four
times in my life stop it right i swear
to god stop it i swear to god three or
four times in your life in my life
have you ever walked the whole thing
that's a must
it's a must i've never you could take
two days in central park from beginning
you go to central how many times have
you been in central park
a hundred
but but why what would you go there for
one of the best places on earth you just
literally take the train or take the
ferry and just go to walk around it okay
there's a zoo i've gone to the zoo i've
explored it all just for exploration i
used to roll a skate through it i filmed
really
so funny to pitch it
when did you like you would bring your
roller skates from staten island just
roller skate yeah i take the ferrari in
the subway and go tie your roller skates
around your shoulder with friends
i might have even just worn my roller
skates into the city this was when i was
really like playing hockey and i would
the skates were like shoes to me and the
day the day would be we're going to
central park to roller skate that's the
day yeah
yeah wow and and and um and and and you
go there's art installations there's
there's so many different looks and even
when you've been there forever and you
think you've seen anything sometimes you
just haven't is it bigger than cloves
lake oh yeah yeah i'll go
uh you go for a picnic i've gone
uh you just had a day in central park go
when it snows sleigh ride and hang out
go to strawberry fields there's a pool
at the top left corner you know up
harlem is there a castle in there too
there's a castle it's gorge
wow we got to do a central park central
park is like
it's awesome should we do the podcast
from central park special episode from
central park let's do a central park
episode 100 i'll do that that's it
that's what we're going to do yeah well
have you been to the bronx zoo yes i
have okay i was worried about you yeah
so the bronx who i have been to wow i
can't believe i've never done anything
yeah and then you got the planetarium
two of the um those museums are right
off the hayden's planetarium hayden it's
central park is up there by yeah i think
it's attached isn't it attached to the
the natural history it's up there
i gotta go you know it starts at like
the park starts at like what like 58th i
think goes up to like one i think 125.
you've walked all 70 blocks 114 i've
i've walked the entire park back fourth
side every part of it every part of it
wow yeah never wow
yeah
yeah no no we don't i get that because
we've got to shoot episodes ever in
central park
we haven't done it in years but the
first like i want to say two three
seasons central park we shot in central
park maybe like no joke like maybe 20 25
times if i go to central park right now
and just walk in the park will find me
the park will lead me the park will lead
you oh you can get out go on paddle
boats i've done that uh the boats with
the with your feet like you know the
you just get a boat you rent a boat
there's a there's a cool uh restaurant
there overlooking the water dude you get
on a boat and you could just go all
around the lakes in central park too the
great lawn there's softball games going
on you could watch people playing
frisbee you can see where john lennon
took a dive wow
you can see all that i never there's a
zoo there's i would always art
installation do you ever go see the
gates remember the gates
no that that i think it was a couple or
a male guy and he did installations all
over the city and he did the gates at
central park
it sounds
like no big deal but it was kind of neat
he basically put like what would be like
a a doorway just a threshold of a door
like a gate and he just put them
one after the other like maybe like 15
feet apart
through the entire park
can you can you put central park the
gates are they still there there they
are you've seen these before pimp well i
went when the installation was there and
i just you know you walk through and
it's there right now today no no this
was this has got to be at least 10 years
ago they're gone now yeah
but he did a bunch of installations all
over the city did you go and see this
pimp
yeah this is forever ago though yeah
like decade joe i'll tell you what i did
too i also made myself a promise not too
long ago i decided long ago
oh anyway yeah if i fail
i didn't because
um
i said i want to start treating new york
like i'm here on vacation wow yeah and
so like i do a little bit of a deep dive
i go a little more granular with it new
york interesting so what do you do just
google stuff like yeah read articles i
get recommendations a couple of forums
and stuff can i start doing this with
you can you please include me on it how
would i not i mean yes you should
because derosa trashed him for the
statement he made on tastebuds yeah he
trashed me for saying that i treat new
york like he trashed both of us yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah no man also every
time we go on the road i do this
elsewhere and i always like it i'm like
new york has this times a hundred yeah
yeah also i've been um i've been thrown
out of my house so would i be able to
stay in your guest room steve it's been
hey babe
has it yeah wow holy cow year one year
52 weeks 52 yeah thank you so much for
the listeners uh who have stayed around
for a year we're closing in on 100 on
200 000 subscribers on youtube on
youtube and
year one look at all the great things
we've been able to do only in year one i
mean we're one years old we still [ __ ]
our pants we still yeah we are that
young this podcast has been great and
another thing we noticed for all the
people that might be listening this
whole time
only and have never checked out the
youtube channel you're missing about 50
of the jokes yeah i'm not discouraging
you not to listen but give it a whirl on
your commute but then if you want to
double back oh boy the sight gag yeah we
you are in for some surprises so thank
you so much a year of hey babe let's get
a lot more years unless one of us dies
suddenly yeah
but then one of us will continue on
and it'll just be hey in spirit we'll do
the show with the ghost of the boy who
died
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe don't
be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey babe hey babe hey
babe hey